it's really not pleasant for your
bare feet to be on snow for a long
period of time because i found my inner
wolf to live in hawkins you've had to
have suffered your fair share of
injuries to be a cast member on the set
of stranger things is no different there
are cuts bruises potential frostbite and
major hits the cast had to go through
number one sadie sink and her stunt
double go full force into vecna's mind
layer this sequence was shot over four
very intense days we dragged the stunt
max on her belly and up against the
pillar they also had to run through this
extremely slippery pan of muddy bloody
water and do their best not to fall not
by accident anyway it also helped that
we had sadie's stunt double take these
awesome wipeouts neither sadie or her
stunt double left this scene unscathed
but yeah it was pretty intense
definitely had some got a little scraped
up number two have you ever run barefoot
through the snow in negative 20 degree
weather before we really hope not but
that's what david harbor had to do while
playing stranger things very own indiana
jones jim hopper it's kind of a brutal
season i mean it was brutal like
physically in that way and it was also
kind of brutal emotionally he also
wasn't eating a lot of food at the time
because jim was supposed to be emaciated
from his time in russia i've been on a
diet of watery soup moldy bread and
maggots this among many reasons is why
11 should definitely get an a on her
diorama project this is my dad his name
is hopper number three we're all
familiar with the scene we need a doctor
call an ambulance something kind of
funny about this one is that caleb
mclaughlin had no idea he'd be shooting
it that day i don't know why but i
remember knowing that i had to do it if
he knew he definitely would have warmed
up his vocal cords oh my god
he opens up about his tough experience
that day i had to lay down on the floor
for like 20 to 30 seconds to just get my
energy back because all i was doing was
crying i lost my voice that week it
definitely took a lot out of me overall
he said he was glad the duffer brothers
didn't tell him beforehand because he
would have majorly overthought
everything number four we don't blame
jonathan for this one i really got it i
got him on the ear and i just remember
his ear being red they practiced that
scene so many times safely yeah to get
the choreography when charlie heaton was
rehearsing he used one vos that was
rubber and one that was breakaway glass
michael park who played the mind player
tom holloway told him that if he gets
hit harder with the breakaway voz it
will hurt less and i was like really
very good and like it was great he was
like really up for it it turns out
that's not always the case
number five luckily it's not real glass
hi there but it still doesn't feel great
digging into your arm i think he got
glass in his hand yeah i think he did at
one point because the glass is made to
break it breaks in really small gritty
pieces that tear at your skin they also
had another type of glass on the set
that was slippery when you stepped on it
basically super dangerous super
dangerous we're running around like
crazy michael park was really going
through it in this hospital hopefully
they were able to treat him after they
wrapped for the day number six every
skater has to fall at some point
see zoomer sadie sink didn't know how to
skateboard before stranger things she
had to learn and i would do like five
hours or three hours of school and then
like three hours of skateboarding
although she had two instructors
teaching her she still ended up with a
nasty injury
jesus
are you all right yeah yeah i was like
skating up a hill and then i just i
completely wiped out she was super
frustrated with the learning curve and
didn't know if she was gonna be able to
pull it off but eventually she managed
to get the hang of it it was fine i mean
you fall it's part of it number seven
luckily stunt people get paid for every
take
[Music]
but then the stunt man he's actually
hitting his head on the desk he hits it
hard i mean you can see this that's not
a joke joe kiri did all of his own
stunts in the sequence and according to
him the phone that he uses to hit the
stunt guy with is made of foam but the
desk where his head lands is
unfortunately not it's like a hard
actual part so wow you did it you wanna
fight number eight millie bobby brown's
vocal cords you good we all know that
eleven's powers don't come from her
ability to scream at the top of her
lungs
it definitely helps get the point across
unfortunately for millie bobby brown she
lost her voice more than once over the
course of filming season three i lost my
voice five times five different times
throughout the eight months of filming i
have to go back into the avr room and
start screaming this means not only did
she have to scream on set but she had to
go back and re-record more screaming
we're hoping they had a ton of hot tea
and honey on deck for her number nine
there were a lot of injuries and mishaps
at the russian base i guess the first
thing i remember is being squished
behind this there's no room back there
gayton matarazzo was grateful for his
lack of collarbones in that situation
but what proved to be even worse was the
hours of squats they had to endure for
the scooby-doo shot man just how cramped
were all of our legs
after being squished and squatting for
hours on end for one shot they were
definitely feeling the repercussions for
days after
number 10 daker montgomery didn't hold
anything back when it came to playing
billy
everyone was physically exhausting as
well i put everything that i had into it
he's really not kidding
lucas sinclair what a surprise
not only was he constantly covered in
cuts and bruises but all the skin off
the top of my toes dragging myself
across the tiles though the physicality
of his scenes took a toll on him all in
all he thinks it was worth it i think it
was just what was necessary and
sometimes you get hurt number 11 the
actors the stunt person and even the
camera crew got their fair share of pain
that day natalia dyer really wanted to
perform her own stunt of being thrown
into the wall but they said absolutely
no way
which looking at it you do yeah it's
pretty and it's pretty intense the stunt
woman for natalia was thrown hard
repeatedly into the wall natalia though
was going through a lot of physical
strain that day herself oh
yeah the stairs
she had to run up and down those stairs
at least 15 times in the most
impractical pair of shoes and they're
very cute they go great with the outfit
they're really really hard to run in
they're really hard to run in this
steadicam operator who had to chase them
down the hallway backwards got a few
major hits as well i think we ran into
him a couple of times i slammed the door
on him once it's quite a painful day
number 12. this one could have been
really bad for maya hawk remember when
you saved my life though she didn't
actually get injured here she really
really almost did there was like gaps in
the thing where the laser was supposed
to be
nearly
off of it it seems like she was getting
a little two method into robin's
clumsiness over there to your right no
you're on the right oh
yeah okay but we're majorly grateful joe
kiri was there to catch her joe just
like action-packed hero style just
grabbed
the cast and crew of stranger things go
through so much just to entertain us we
hope they have more than one first aid
kit on set honestly more like a doctor
on deck which injury do you think was
the most painful to bear
[Music]